uh but today he was supposed to appear
at the garter ceremony in fact his name
was on the order of service so he was
definitely coming and was going to wear
all the robes this is by the way an
order for chivalry i mean the irony
is not lost on us but at the last minute
we're told prince charles and prince
william directly intervened with we
assume the queen to say he cannot talk
that's the household put him on there
right and then he saw it see back in the
day what people used to do that andrew's
accused of they vanished yes they went
and worked in soup kitchens or they
helped the homeless and he's banished
for about two months of anybody well
that's my point uh esther because my i
know your view about the monarchy
generally but my point is if you again
want to hasten the end of the monarchy
then you would allow someone like
someone like andrew to make a comeback
within two months but that's the
householder millions and millions of
dollars right so i just think he can't
do this he can't be allowed to do the
man has no judgment he's so arrogant and
has no sense no sense of you know
reality why do you think that you are
such you are such a blessing to public
life and public service that you have to
show your that's the age we're in nobody
wants to vanish okay so no no seriously
so nobody has said to him look dude what
you actually should be doing now you
should be actually volunteering like
what profumo did in the 60s right at 20
yeah and he went and he helped the poor
and he died
he's got two daughters who are both
heavily involved in anti-sex trafficking
right get involved with beatrice and
eugene
well actually
one of the things one of the things he
apparently does want he wants them to
both be allowed to be working royals i i
feel incredibly sorry for his daughters
and i know them i know one very well
she's a delightful young lady always
thought they're behaved impeccably
themselves through no fault of their own
suddenly they're out of the main royal
list they're off the ball
andrew demanded when beatrice was born
that she'd be a princess she was not
automatically meant to be a princess he
demanded it from his mom who adores him
and his next child to be a princess so
he's always wanted that because that
reflects on him but if he was a really
modest
he should actually just vanish
i actually i believe in second chances
for people right
but not like 12.
not not for everything i think i do
believe a second chance for people and
it has to be said that legally he's
never admitted any crime he's done an
out-of-court settlement in a civil
action so we just need to remember
but then
he becomes whether he likes it or not
he's born into a role model situation
and what he needs to show people now is
how you put be a public servant without
being in the party
he's gotta he's gonna earn
his rights i don't i don't think so i'm
sorry even if we put all the allegations
aside he was still friends with the
known convicted pedophile and he went on
record in an interview and admitted it
and showed his lack his complete lack of
judgment i think you can't come back
from okay no i don't think he ever
should come back let me just yeah let me
just cheer the mood slightly
a moment at the weekend where britney
spears
the king
elvis the king so britney spears got got
married at the weekend and she had elvis
presley
as she walked down the aisle let's take
a little look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now one of the guests at the wedding was
paris hilton
the socialite from los angeles there
they are amazing picture was this vegas
this was not vegas i'm not quite sure
where it was actually but they anyway
elvis was the theme paris hilton's there
and this is personal to me ladies
because it may come as some surprise to
you but i myself
well before i play the clip well just
wait for you you've actually hit them on
the head so there was a little furore
that blew up several weeks ago when
elvis elvis's estate
banned elvis look-alikes and
impersonators from performing at vegas
wedding series horrible and they've just
rescinded the band they've lifted it so
the elvises are back into they and this
is personal for me bonnie because i
actually married paris hilton in a vegas
chapel with elvis presley there have
been you mary paris watch
you here's morgan take periscope to be
your wedded wife
[Music]
but i'm keeping the ring
and she did keep the ring and uh suffice
it to say it it didn't last but it was a
magical day but i'm just so glad that
elvis has been saved for vegas that's
ridiculous
we wouldn't remember him if he wasn't
exactly now what's the worst job you've
ever done ah
anyone i lived with a hundred men what
yes i worked in an i.t training center
in france and i lived with all my
students and they're about a hundred men
that's horrific in my early days in new
york i took a job as a cleaner and with
a feminist painter and so i went to
clean her house i was very excited
because i thought her paintings were
going to be there actually she wanted me
to wash her underwear oh and this was a
feminist painter i left i can imagine i
worked for selena blair it was before i
got into fleet street i was trying to
make some money and i was tasked with
stitching buttons onto these very
expensive designer anyone that has seen
me with needle and thread knows that's
the last thing you should give me
something i had to spend one hot
steaming summer in the 70s bagging
mushroom compost in a field in east
sussex with my brother uh who became an
army colonel and did many war zones and
said that the mushrooms was the worst
thing he ever had to endure but the
reason i'm asking you is that last uh
about three weeks ago
i said that the worst job in the world
was when i heard that madonna was
auditioning for a new toy boy and i
thought that would be the worst job in
the world but it's been quickly
overtaken because we now have a new
winner which may never be beaten
actually president vladimir putin's
bodyguard apparently has to scoop his
excrement from the toilet during trips
abroad and store it in a special briefs
case this is reportedly to stop foreign
powers stealing the stools to gather
information on his health i think we can
all agree
that is the most thankless job well you
know
did not want him to actually didn't want
to have a test because he didn't want
his dna in russia it's your dna
uh
it's your dna
i'm rarely speechless you might imagine
but that is your dna or it may be that
he's got various illnesses which they
don't want
i would think that's very much more
likely very true ladies great to see you
great panel come back soon thank you
very much